I'm a lazy language learner I don't do
tests I don't do flashcards I don't use
the International Phonetic Alphabet the
IPA I don't go to class I study on my
own when I feel like it when I'm tired
of whatever I'm doing I move on to
something else I fluctuate between
difficult content and easy
content the well-known and outstanding
Brazilian educator described why
comprehension tests about things that we
read are so futile because reading is a
vagabond experience we don't want to
challenge the reader to try to remember
or try to understand or to explain what
he or she read we just want the reader
to enjoy the process and so that's kind
of been my
Approach now there are definitely
arguments against the sort of lazy
language learning attitude I've read a
couple of books recently that give
reasons why we need to be more
deliberate although with the Nuance
outsmarting our brains by Dan Willingham
making it stick now these books do point
out that sort of deliberate block
learning forcing yourself to learn
something is not very effective however
they and others like Justin Sun whom you
can find on YouTube and I'll leave a
link and many others point out that
retrieval is very effective if you're
forcing yourself to try to remember
something as in tests the effort of
retrieving things helps anchor things in
our long-term memory or you need to have
it structured so that you're learning
things that are at that proximal zone of
capability or of knowledge so that
you're never attacking anything that's
too too difficult for you and of course
that's the difficulty in a classroom
because the teacher doesn't know what
each student knows so how can they then
give them just that next level that
proximal level of difficulty and then
there's Bloom's taxonomy where it's not
enough to retrieve things we also have
to develop the ability to discuss to
evaluate and to understand things that
we are learning but that then brings me
to why I think lazy language learning is
the best approach for language learning
when we're talking about language we're
not talking about developing or
retaining with accuracy bits of
information that we have learned we're
talking about using the content the
material that's hopefully of interest to
us to learn the language when I read a
history book on Poland in Polish I don't
care if I remember all the details I'm
not going to do a a test on polish
history I'm just aware that just by
reading and listening in Polish to
whatever it might be my ability in the
language is
improving again this zone of proximal
knowledge because we are selecting
things of interest to us we are
typically moving from one bit of content
in a particular area using a podcast or
an audiobook or whatever it might be to
something that is more or less related
to that subject so we are helping
ourselves both in terms of the subject
matter and in terms of the vocabulary
stay within our area of proximal
knowledge similarly when I start out in
a language I do a lot of repetitive
listening to our mini stories because
there again I'm staying within the
limits of my sort of proximal level of
knowledge another advantage of this lazy
approach is that it keeps me motivated
because whatever theoretically can be
said about the advantages of retrieval
practice and testing and these other
things if it demotivates me then it
actually is
counterproductive similarly with say
trying to learn the basics of grammar up
front if I find that a demotivating
thing to do even if it could be proven
that it helps me master the grammar
which I don't believe to be the case if
it demotivates me then it's a bad thing
to
do given that retrieval is an important
part of developing long-term memory so
then some might argue we should be doing
tests to force us to retrieve things
that we have learned however when we are
listening and reading covering a lot of
different types of material maybe some
of the same essential subject matter
using different books or different
sources we are in fact forcing ourselves
to retrieve things that we have in our
memory so we don't have to have a
deliberate retrieval practice or
exercise that's going to force us to
retrieve things by the mere fact that we
are reading and listening to things
things where there are words that are in
various stages of being acquired so in
the case of link if they're white we
know them if they're different shades of
yellow we're in different stages of
learning them if they're blue they're
brand new by listening and reading we
are again retrieving them so that the
exercise of retrieving takes place
naturally in an input based learning
style the big thing of course is to
remain curious it's our curiosity that
drives us curiosity about the language
about the people so as long as we have
that Curiosity and we have that sort of
lazy attitude it's almost the sort of
woo way effortless attitude of Zen or of
druna in in Chinese philosophy we're
going to be moving forward even though
we have a lazy approach to language
learning and we resist the testing and
the other things that traditional
classroom instruction tries to force on
us and I think we are living in the
Golden Age of Vagabond or lazy language
learning never has there been a greater
variety of resources available through
YouTube through podcasts and I now
discovered that I can go to a podcast
and even if the MP3 file isn't available
I can turn on the audio open up audacity
get an MP3 file and then I can bring
that MP3 file into link link will
automatically transcribe it I have a
lesson so the fields the areas that we
can wander around Meander around like a
hobo like a vagabond as a lazy language
learner and increase our ability in the
language has never been greater I have
spoken previously on the subject of lazy
language learning and I will leave you a
couple of videos that I did at different
stages and with this video I'm kind of
updating my position on this thank you
for listening bye for now